[Music]
every friday night graham norton charms
uk
audiences with britain's version of the
late night talk show
his sharp comedic timing unique laugh
and effortless ease with guests who chat
with him over drinks on his famous red
sofa
have made the graham norton show a huge
success
many also watch the show online where
some clips have gotten more than 20
million views
on youtube norton an eight-time bafta
award winner also hosts a radio show
and he found time to write his third
novel home stretch
which goes on sale in the u.s tomorrow
we spoke to him about that
and his tv show and we've got a picture
of you at the emmys
you are so provocative graeme i've told
some shockers on the show before come on
jamie
she went like this
by the way this is the best time i've
ever had on the talk show
[Applause]
the unexpected often happens on the
graham norton show
[Applause]
oh my god did you just drink the fly i
think it's that thing that
no matter how much planning you put into
it now how much production
and prep on the night you are
not sure what you're gonna get never
been to a nightclub yes you have
i bumped into you in heaven
the world's biggest stars are drawn to
norton's famous couch
but i feel though colin sometimes i feel
too
it's very high status your name is over
the door you walk out at the beginning
the audience go
yay you feel great aren't i fabulous
but the minute the guests come out then
you've got to be low status
your job at that point is to make the
other people look good and if you find
you're talking too much you know
something's gone horribly wrong
it's a chat show not a whispering show
it's gone right for the irishman for 23
years now
but the tv host also has an unexpected
side
as an author i think a lot of people
would expect that if you wrote a novel
it would be set in some sort of glitzy
london world
but your books are set in very quaint
towns in ireland well because
that's where i grew up home stretch
norton's third novel
is about an irish boy who survives a car
crash
that kills three friends the young man
ultimately leaves ireland just as norton
did
and later returns to a changed country
i think it's the first country in the
world where gay marriage was brought in
through a popular vote through a
referendum
that blows my mind if you told the me
leaving ireland in 1984 that that would
happen
i would have just thought no that's
science fiction you pay tribute at the
end of your book
to all the people who stayed and fought
for that change i did because
because there is a kind of guilt when i
go back
and reap the benefits you know i'm
swanning around
going i mean not that i'm getting
married but i could
norton wandered far after leaving his
home country
you ended up at one point at a commune
in san francisco i've lived anthony i've
lived
yes but in 1989 norton nearly died
after he was stabbed during a mugging in
west london
i lost half my blood i was in hospital
for a few weeks
and it's only looking back now that i
realize how traumatic it was
i can imagine how that would stay with
you for a long long time in a way it
made me fearless it made me
make braver decisions i think yeah in
that what's the worst that could happen
well that's the worst that could happen
so everything else is sort of you know
if you do a show that bombs or you get
terrible reviews for a book
well not dead there's something about
being gay oh
it's just a bit common now i wasn't just
norton first got noticed
as a rather raunchy stand-up comedian in
fairness i'm not that hot
and yet jason i might be later i was
never very good
i was okay i could make a living but i
wasn't a closer
so the minute i got some radio and tv
gigs and could get out of there
i did along with his long-running talk
show
norton also loves being britain's host
of the eurovision song contest the
world's biggest live music event
and this year i think people really
embraced it and it is the stupidest show
on earth if people haven't seen it
i can't describe it to them because it's
so billy bonkers but being
an author is graham norton's great
escape this is what homecoming meant
arriving in a place to discover you're
fluent in a language
you'd forgotten you ever knew i get the
sense you'll you'll keep writing
long as you can do it i do hope so it's
this lovely refuge
it's just me i'm alone and i really like
that having said that i'm supposed to be
writing book four now
i'm talking to you what a hoot of a guy
yeah you know it's so interesting
because part of the reason he loves
writing is he kind of doesn't have to be
the graham norton everybody knows yeah
and he can go off into that space and he
said i kind of
you know i didn't want to be people to
be thinking about graham norton while
they start reading this book
so he sets them in these very quiet
places in ireland the first couple were
mysteries
this is this is just a pure novel and i
assume
book four is going to be fiction as well
but based on his answers to your
questions i'd read a memoir when he said
he didn't
live yes he did he started he did he's
done a memoir in england i don't know if
it came out here but that's what got him
the fiction deal he said basically i was
like
i told him you want my memoir fine you
got to take my novel too you have i have
discovered someone new i mean
and i love the premise of his show he
has such a huge
cast of characters it's the best you get
the best guests in britain i mean what a
mix yeah all from all over the world
so fun he's got various ideas on what
the the key is to a great interview i do
think alcohol helps yes a little bit who
knew